tigers and twins it's the start of a
five-game weekend series it starts with
a double header
branding domnick as you said a little
rough start in his last timeout but he's
looking to rebound here
and the 1-2 pitch a swing and a
strikeout foul tip hung onto
by ryan jeffers on a sinker from randy
righty on righty match up the two ones
swinging a ground ball base hit he
squeezed it in between adrianza and
polanco
they were shifted in scope as that ball
goes into left center scoots over to
third
runners at the corners one out and the
o2 pitch he got him strike three on a
slider
and that's a strikeout pitch now 15 of
his
19 strikeouts on his slider two on two
out and the 1-0 pitch is cue to the
ground to third
charging is donaldson will throw to
first in time and that's out number
three
and the tigers leave two we played one
half it's been a rough go for him but a
little better in his last start and
he's giving up a lot of hits i think the
twins are gonna have to take what he
gives you he's going to try and induce
soft contact and you got to use the big
part of the field off this guy
and the payoff pitch is swinging a fly
ball into left field and deep
stewart going back on the track stewart
at the wall jumps up that's gone
lead off home run polanco polanco's
fourth homer this season a lead-off shot
a 3-2
count and the twins strike first and
take a one-nothing lead
now donaldson made his return to the
twins lineup on wednesday night missed
all of august with a right calf injury
swinging a drive into center field
that's a d back it goes deep it goes and
that ball is gone
what a start to this double header two
batters in
two nothing twins on homers from polanco
and donaldson
that's the center and that'll fall for a
hit
and cruises the board with the third
straight hit against matthew boyd
bruce among the league leaders in
batting came into the
baton in 3 26. the 3-2
swinging a high fly ball shallow into
right field coming over and in demerit
he stops makes the catch
good bounce back after a home run home
run singles started the ending
former first round pick in 2015 three
homers nine knocked in
batting just 188 pitch swinging the line
drive basin into left field fastballed
down and stewart was on it
sharp line drive single the opposite way
that's three singles for the tigers
two on nobody out and the one pitcher
ground ball to the right side this is
played by adrianza
second for one the return is in time and
there's a double play
taking third is stuart but that was
anything but routine because adrianza
was blocked by the second base umpire
alex tosi and the 3-2 he got him strike
three on a good sinker
dipping down and inside so the tigers
make noise two on nobody up they don't
score in leave one
cave strung together a couple of really
good games had a good series with the
white sox four for 10. he homer drove in
three
the 3-2 slider got him on the outside
corner beautiful pitch
rose cave that's the art of pitching
right there perfect pitch
swung on and missed left the zone out
number two
here in the second the 1-0 back up the
middle diving stop made by scope and he
shoveled it perfectly
to willy castro to get the force another
base runner for the twins
ground ball to short castro to scope to
candelario beautifully turned
six four three double play that was a
soft ground ball and crude still runs
well
the two two swing and a miss he did it
back to back to back with a change up
down and away he's
one out and now the batter is going to
be willie castro there's a number off
the end of the bat
be fueled by domnick had a better hurry
he does
so one pitch he nubs it off the end of
the back castro easy out christian
stewart
he's singled his first time up here's
the 2-0 pitch and popped up
shallow left field rooker in and it's
going to be donaldson
making a running catch with his back to
the infield
and donaldson stayed with a nice running
catch that's the old receiver catch
right there
don't mind it into a 4-6-3 double play
his first time up
check swank see if he went they said he
did and romine
will head back to the dugout and hit the
right field fairly well marwin
back on the warning track he'll have
room and puts it away
santa go and left the bat just a routine
fly ball out
duffy is on for the 15th time 17
strikeouts and
14 and one third innings worked and the
1-2 pitch he got him strike three
fastball from duffy so scope strikes out
swinging
up and in two outs twins by two sixth
inning bases empty
and the o2 pitch he got him strike three
three fastballs in down goes cabrera
and tyler duffy comes in with a one two
three
sixth inning striking out two taylor
rogers has the ball right now three outs
away from the save and a twins win
tying run now comes up for the tigers
candelarios at third and the l1 ground
ball to third donaldson will play this
one looks the runner back throws across
in time to get him for out number two
and the 3-2 pitch he got him strike
three
swinging and the twins win the game
shutting out the tigers two-nothing